aujourd'hui jeudi 3 septembre 2015
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction bienvenue sur tv fils si vous
venez de nous rejoindre nous parlerons
de la mobilisation des agriculteurs des
agriculteurs de toute la france sont
venus sur paris ils sont en colère et
surtout inquiets pour l'avenir de leur
profession nous irons aussi sur le
chantier du golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines qui se prépare des
travaux sont en cours avant l'accueil de
la ryder cup 2018 le tourisme se porte
bien dans les yvelines le point complet
est de la saison estivale à suivre et en
plateau pour en parler tout à l'heure le
comte paul de la panouse le fondateur et
du parc de thoiry le château qui est
d'ailleurs ouvert depuis à 50 ans nous
devrions aussi aller tout à l'heure du
côté de mantes la jolie pour retrouver
sur place lors de la conférence de
presse de rentrée de la fsu le syndicat
enseignant williams elle pour la
rédaction nous ferons un point sur les
revendications la situation telle que
telle qu'elle est perçue par le syndicat
enseignant fsu bonsoir paul de la
panouse
bienvenue sur ce plateau fondateur du
parc animalier de thoiry c'était en 67
68 mais on fait tout de même un
cinquantième anniversaire cette année
puisque cela fait 50 ans que le château
lui a été ouvert au public qu'on vient
d'un petit peu pour débuter ce journal
sur cette idée d'ouvrir le château en
1965 pourquoi pas le château avait perdu
à la révolution française ses fonctions
de mairie où ce fils d'arrondissement
avec la suppression des droits féodaux
et ce n'était plus que donc l'habitation
d'une famille traditionnelle d'une
famille
alors quand j 21 ans j'ai demandé à mes
parents jean et d'écouté moi j'aurais
pas les moyens que vous avez deux vendu
l'habitat tous les emplois des quatre
frères et soeurs pour tenir les deux
châteaux familiaux il faut que nous où
j'essaye d'en faire quelque chose
dois faire ma vie ailleurs et alors j'ai
demandé l'autorisation mes parents
d'ouvrir le château public pour lui
donner une fonction sociale 21 ans 1 par
une activité culturelle et les revenus
d'entrée de la billetterie a été perçu
comme ans mes parents c'est une bonne
idée remarquable beaucoup de sang social
et agricoles et là du coup forestier
dans les domaines avec forestier de la
famille alors pourquoi pas être ces
salles aussi dans le tourisme en passe
de l'un à l'autre partir du moment où
son coeur on peut ouvrir la maison et
c'était le cas de la dans lequel était
mais l'état d'esprit la qualité de mes
parents
et depuis le succès est au rendez vous
cette année encore les animations
organisées notamment autour des
dinosaures alors c'est un parc animalier
mais il ya aussi des dinosaures vous est
peut-être allé cet été une exposition
qui a été menée des maquettes géantes
grandeur nature venus des états unis et
ça a rencontré un succès fou on va en
parler
elle se sera prolongée tout au long du
mois de septembre on les voit ses
maquettes et les enfants qui s'en amuse
beaucoup
globalement à l'été a été très bon sur
les différents sites touristiques ce
sera l'objet du dossier ce soir du
journal mais l'actualité du jour c'est
bien sûr la mobilisation des
agriculteurs
près de 1400 tracteurs ont roulé dans
paris venant de toute la france et
notamment des yvelines ce qui a entraîné
quelques perturbations sur les routes
vous voyez une démonstration de force et
premiers résultats obtenus cette
déclaration d'amour de manuel valls
la france ne lâchera pas ces
agriculteurs les crédits d'urgence
annoncées en juillet seront donc
augmenter et des tests sur une
simplification des normes aussi seront
données
retour sur cette journée avec mélanie
poquet et patrick jacques de dixmude la
nationale 12
une soixantaine de tracteurs yvelinois
et d'eure-et-loir se dirige vers paris
dans leur viseur les normes imposées par
le ministère de l'agriculture qu'il juge
étouffante
on a des charges franco-françaises
important du social et de l'autre on
vous fait courir un 100 m avec un boulet
au pied
il faut absolument que l'on ne puisse
appliqué on veut appliquer la
réglementation européenne et là on nous
rajoute des réglementations françaises
un exemple aucune jachère n'est fait en
allemagne
et nous nous avons dix pour cent des
jachères un même marché pour les
producteurs européens mais des charges
différentes une situation précaire pour
les producteurs français éleveurs
maraîchers mais aussi céréaliers et
notamment les yvelinois moi je me suis
installé en 2000 à une époque où en
pourparlers en euros on vendait du blé
135 140 euros comme elles courent
actuellement c'est ça qui est
intéressant
sauf que je m'étais ça me coûtait 95 à
100 heureux produire une tonne de blé
aujourd'hui ça me coûte 125 euros
conduirait une tonne de blé donc en
quinze ans plus de 25 à 30% de plus de
coûts de production en ile-de-france les
différents cortèges ont occasionné 100
km de bouchons à 9 heures après avoir
reçu les représentants de la fnsea et
des jeunes agriculteurs le premier
ministre manuel valls annoncé la mise en
place d'un moratoire juste pour février
2016 pour qu'aucune norme
environnementale française allant au
delà de la législation européenne ne
soit adoptée ainsi que des êtres total
porté à 3 milliards d'euros en trois ans
voilà donc pour ce point sur cette
journée de mobilisation est qu'en pensez
vous de cette mobilisation comprenez
vous les revendications des agriculteurs
nous vous avons posé la question dans
les rues de saint quentin en yvelines
micro-trottoir agriculteurs aujourd'hui
oui bien sûr j'étais agriculteur à
voisins-le-bretonneux pendant et mon
grand père mon père ariel wasa comprends
je la comprends est avec les prix sont
superbes a pour moi ils comptent pas
leurs heures
donc faudrait un peu les respecter voilà
les aider c'est clair 8 août a fait ce
que mon père l'utilisait agriculteurs
ils sont pas entendus et c'est vrai il
aimerait bien vivre de leurs propres
moyens et paca par les subventions
oui pour les petits agriculteurs pour
les céréaliers je suis beaucoup plus
dubitatif
ce sont plus des industriels que des
agriculteurs je suis complètement
solidaire c'est incroyable ce qu'ils
font pour en arriver là je trouve c'est
honteux quoi voilà donc pour ce point
sur la mobilisation aujourd'hui on en
revient à l'entretien le dossier de ce
jour on parle de tourisme donc avec
notre invité le comte paul de la panouse
fondateur du parc de thoiry on évoquait
au début de ce journal le 50e
anniversaire d'ouverture du château au
public
un bel anniversaire puisque la
fréquentation était bonne cet été telle
a été la fréquentation est excellente
cette était vraiment excellente le temps
elle était bien paru quelques jours
d'orage qui ont permis au gazon de
d'autres venir tout vert et des
antilopes en sont ravis mais la
fréquentation on est très très content
surtout voilà vous savez combien de
personnes ont fréquenté le site
en chiffres oh je ne sais pas mais bon
notre objectif était de retrouver nos
450 mille visiteurs et en étant dans
l'espoir d'y arriver
il ya eu une petite baisse au moment de
l'ouverture de bassel mais les gens qui
en a fait un gros travail de rénovation
et sa wii ou le fait partir les
visiteurs de chez vous alors et puis lui
attend très mobile elle et l'a liée à
une météo très mauvais mais alors cette
année la météo a été tout à fait bonnes
et pays et les gens sont venus voir
thoiry
et surtout les dinosaures un succès
considérable c'est l'effet dinosaures 12
reproduction installé dans le parc
grandeur nature d'où vient cette idée de
mettre des dinosaures dont les
particuliers c'est l'idée que les
animaux préhistoriques vous les voyez en
squelette au muséum d'histoire naturelle
et dans le château je n'ai pas présenté
mes ancêtres en squelette il ya des
tableaux il ya des statuts alors
pourquoi pas pour les animaux mettent
leurs ancêtres grandeur nature et qui
bougeait comme l'elysée à ma américains
ont fait des reconstitutions remarquable
des dinosaures comme dans les films à
télé où on voit à partir d'accra l'on
vous refaire la tête de la personne qui
était là c'est ce qu'ils ont fait avec
les dinosaures et séibou gyan n'a même
ainsi on s'approche de trop près qui
vous crachent de l'original ya 200
millions d'années crash and has it vous
avez pas pousser la reconstitution
fiscaux mongomin de même voilà va pas
pousser la reconstitution du co voilà
d'ailleurs du coup les gens profitaient
avec la chaleur ceci étant quand il ya
eu une période de canicule est haute à
thoiry nous avons installé des fontaines
d'eau potable partout sur le parcours
pour eux pour faire que les gens ne
soient pas obligés d'acheter des grès
d'eau en bouteille minérales twice un
théâtre de la nature un théâtre de
l'histoire forte on a payé son billet
d'entrée on peut amener son pique nique
et on n'est pas obligé d'acheter quoi
que ce soit donc ça c'est le grand
principe de votre philosophie
vous évoquiez la canicule et alors côté
visiteurs mais côté animaux ça a été
difficile à gérer aussi cette période de
chaleur
non pas du tout parce que d'abord les
animaux la réserve africaine sont tout à
fait heureux de retrouver un climat qui
ressemble un peu à celle et est ensuite
ici il n'ya pas y'a pas de sécheresse à
l'anglais il ya toujours autant de
freins qu'arrive autant d'eau carrick
donc les animaux des animaux du froid
s'adapte très bien au chaud parce qu'un
ours polaires au canada peut avoir 40
degrés pont
un mois d'été par contre les animaux du
sound ça n'a pas au froid dans cet
univers qu'il faut s'occuper de chauffer
les girafes et les antilopes les
éléphants et caetera et préparent l'été
d'autres absolument aucun problème c'est
à ce niveau là alors c'est le
traditionnel sorbet aux macros pour les
ours orbeo sens pour les lions sorbet
aux fruits pour les singes les primates
pour ça ça beaucoup de succès auprès du
public il ya 24 il ya chaque jour 24
animation 2d qui peut voir les animaux
nourrissent les animaux voilà tout à
fait et surtout le dis à tous ceux qui
prennent des passeports il y avait 3000
familles et on et ça augmente tout le
temps vous avez réussi à fidéliser parce
que les gens viennent sur le parc mais
aussi la pas pour le prêt de l'entrée on
peut venir tous les jours d'ouverture
c'est à dire 200 caprins jours par an et
ça marche ça fonctionne quand elle
fonctionne très très bien alors là on
ferme le mercredi j'ai dit actuellement
en septembre en semaine mais tous les
journées tout qu'on sera ouvert jusqu'à
la lie de les dinosaures dont nous
parlions ils vont rester encore un peu
sa rencontré un tel succès que vous avez
trop louis
c'est passionnant on voit que des gosses
quatre ans qui sait pas lire les pailles
et écrire arrive et vous donne tous les
noms dédié des dinosaures dont
connaissent par coeur
et alors voilà donc et alors les
descendants des dinosaures il existait
ça qu'on essaie de témoigner les oiseaux
par contre at war et nous avons les
dragons de komodo qui sont très rares
dragon de komodo alors tout le monde
pense qu'ils descendent des dinosaures
pas du tout et décembre deux cousins des
dinosaures par contre ils sont restés
très proches de l'ancêtre il ya 65
millions d'années
ils ont une langue bifide essayer les
parents sont les ancêtres des serpents
cet intarissable sur le sujet on
pourrait faire tout le journal rien que
sur ça mais bon on va poursuivre malgré
tout on parlait de ce bilan
bon bilan même pour le tourisme dans
l'ensemble du département château de
versailles également le parc de france
miniature à elancourt les détails tout
de suite avec mélanie poquet sephora
nani et on revient en plateau juste
après faites vous pour l'été 2015 les
nouveautés proposées aux visiteurs de
france miniature se sont révélées
payantes pour la fréquentation
le site a vu une augmentation importante
+ 10 % par rapport à 2014 si on regarde
historiquement c'est un niveau d'été
qu'on connaissait sur les années 2012
2011 donc presque un retour à la normale
2014 avait été décevant et 2015 nous
permet de revenir à un niveau d'environ
60 mille visiteurs sur le parc de france
miniature pour le mois de juillet et le
mois d'août est un sentiment qui se
ressent dans le département en général
la saison touristique étant jugée plutôt
bonne part les professionnels du
tourisme
beaucoup de choses nouvelles par rapport
aux autres années
une meilleure notoriété sur sur internet
qui nous a qui nous a permis d'avoir de
bonnes fréquentations
et puis malgré tout il n'y a pas eu
beaucoup de pluie donc forcément ça
permet de développer les fréquentations
seul bémol le château de versailles la
saison est jugée moins bonne que celle
de 2014 année qualifiée d'exceptionnelle
les chiffres de fréquentation sont en
baisse de 5% pour le mois d'août 2015
les français viennent moins au domaine
national de versailles mais aussi qui à
certains marchés qui sont en baisse à
cause des raisons de sécurité en janvier
les attentats qu'on a eu
en france à paris on fait peur à des
nationalités étrangères comme la russie
par exemple et comme le japon la saison
touristique n'est cependant pas terminée
les réservations dans les hôtels
yvelinois pour le mois de septembre sont
engageante
retour sur ce bel été connue dans ce
département des yvelines la
fréquentation touristique du parc de
tours et on l'a évoqué dans le reportage
on entendait le cas des étrangers aussi
la fréquentation venus des autres pays
est ce que touahri accueille beaucoup de
touristes étrangers
vous avez une renault vers 10 heures
difficiles à voir parce qu'on accueille
les étrangers résidant en france en
région parisienne viennent à thoiry
d'autant plus les anglais les hollandais
également que son habituelle dans les
parc zoologique encore plus que les
français
mais c'est pas facile de les remarquer
parce qu'ils ont des voitures françaises
il parle souvent aussi bien français et
donc voie nous avons une avions beaucoup
de visiteurs russes donc
là il ya eu effectivement une baisse est
semble-t-il et touahri n'est pas nous
avons beaucoup beaucoup sur les familles
ile de france normandie qui sont la
majorité de notre public
autre point soulevé familles qui
accueillent des familles il faut les
faire revenir aussi on l'a évoqué avec
la question du passeport vous avez mis
en place 2 pour finalement très bien
dans le reportage justement c'est la
question de la nouveauté il faut savoir
se renouveler pour continuer à attirer
les gens vous l'avez fait avec les
dinosaures par exemple pendant cet été
en permanence vous pensez vous avez des
nouvelles idées y en a aura des est
votée il ya des nouveautés de prévues
les annonces pas encore un paysan et
tant que c'est pas un éleveur et tom
c'est parfait
je ne veux pas en parler parce que si
jamais pour par créer une déception si
jamais un investissement pour des
raisons techniques ou des raisons et les
animaux s'est basé sur les animaux et
les animaux ces programmes d'élevage et
on ne reproduit pas
c'est pas comme une chaîne de voitures
où on dit y avoir ajouté une voiture bon
va passer trois jours de clients plus de
robots et des personnes non et donc il
faut être
nous nous adaptons aussi aux nécessités
du programme quand il ya un directeur de
programme ni ou alors là attention j'ai
des animaux qui vont être placés et tout
ce que vous auriez pas une idée de dents
de faire quelque chose bon bah c'est ma
fille collombat va réagir en regardant
s'il ne peut pas faire une animation qui
permettent d'aider ce programme la place
et ses animaux il y aura des nouveautés
dans la règle après la trêve hivernale
puisque le parc fermera autour du mois
de novembre
à la fin novembre il fait en fin
novembre pour ouvrir en février une
toute dernière question depuis 50 ans le
château est ouvert et on l'a dit tout à
l'heure 68 pour le parc animalier
vous l'imaginez comment votre parc dans
50 ans a tout bien c'est pas moi qui
serait relié qui ressemble à quoi
il ya des domaines dont je souhaite
qu'il ne change pas c'est qu'on ne
rajoute pas une aile au château car le
château on découvre de plus en plus sa
qualité architecturale autour du nombre
d'or du solstice et où nous avons de
plus en plus
d
les compagnonnages les druides les
formations spiritualiste qui viennent
dans le château pour profiter de sa
fonction solaires et autres
donc il ya des choses qui ne doivent pas
changer d art que j'ai planté que je ne
verrai qui vont me survivre très
longtemps donc ça j'imagine très bien
comme ils sont donc je peux vraiment
région at war est un rêve à long terme
il ya des projets qu'on a imaginé il ya
très longtemps quand on a planté le
labyrinthe on a attendu saison que ça
pousse
vous avez dans touahri des choses comme
cela qui on vient de refaire le mur du
potager limite entre le village et le
château pour agrandir la rue du village
refaire le mur du potager un jour on va
restaurer le potager mais c'est un
travail de cette année par les aînés à
ce que je ne vois moi c'est fini c'est
mes enfants maintenant
mais bon on continue à mener des
missions ce soir tous très bien et bien
merci beaucoup
le conte paul de la panouse qui était
l'invité du journal ont parlé à tourisme
ce soir c'était le dossier de cette
édition merci à vous je rappelle
l'animation autour des dinosaures qui se
poursuit tout le mois de septembre
merci encore le tourisme qui se porte
bien dans le département vous l'avez
entendu grâce notamment en raison du
beau temps
raison de plus pour regretter la
fermeture du centre aquatique de la
piscine de maurepas en raison de son
insalubrité elle n'a pas ouvert ses
portes cet été le maire réfléchit à sa
rénovation voire même à une
reconstruction il a visité ces dernières
semaines plusieurs équipements à
chevreuse ou encore à chartres
ecoutez-le un cabinet d'étude a été
retenu dans le cadre d'un appel d'offres
ce cabinet nous rendra ses conclusions
d'ici le mois de décembre pour savoir
s'il faut réhabiliter la piscine ne mord
pas qu'ils aient de 1975 ou s'il vaut
mieux partir vers un nouveau projet un
nouveau complexe aquatique sur la ville
de maurepas donc nous serons éclairé
d'ici quelques mois
mais en attendant
je visite différents équipements dans
les yvelines nous pouv oir même au delà
pour voir comment les élus locaux s'y
sont pris dans le cadre d'une
réhabilitation ou d'une reconstruction
et m'inspirer de ce qui se fait de mieux
la fsu syndicat enseignant tient en ce
moment sa conférence de presse de
rentrée dans les yvelines c'est à
mantes-la-jolie sur place on retrouve de
williams elle les familles bourdillon
williams bonsoir quel est le quel est le
bilan williams de cette rentrée y at il
des difficultés notables dans le
primaire ou dans le secondaire pour la
fsu oui bon il ya des difficultés qui
sont rencontrés et spécifiquement alors
wilfried je retrouve notre syndicat est
premier et du second degré rejoint comme
s le tweet pas encore le snep
alors pourquoi en ta jolie cet effet
subi la nouvelle partenaire justin
vaisse collège proposition avec la
presse donc cette rencontre organisée
avec la presse les différents pour
problème te les mêmes toujours la
réforme des collèges carte bleue viseur
concerne l'autonomie des établissements
comme finalité mais il ment personnalisé
des élèves
williams williams malheureusement je
sais pas si vous nous entendez bien on a
du mal à stabiliser la liaison on va
revenir sur le plateau on va juste voilà
on va juste devoir interrompre la
communication avec williams elle qui se
trouve du côté de mantes-la-jolie et
dans le département pour se prendre
entrée du syndicat enseignant fsu et si
on arrive à rétablir correctement la
connaissent une connexion nous
repartirons dans quelques instants
on va parler de sport maintenant dans ce
journal le chantier qui a débuté
récemment c'est celui du parcours de
l'albatros du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en 2018 le
site va accueillir la ryder cup
compétition de référence par équipes
entre les meilleurs européens et les
meilleurs américains huit mois de
travaux nécessaires pour permettre à
l'équipement de devenir une référence
mondiale pour les 25 prochaines années
michael et demi d'euros et patrick
jacques de dixmude à la ryder cup 2018
se prépare dès maintenant au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
d'importants travaux de rénovation ont
été entrepris sur le parcours de
l'albatros depuis le 7 juillet dernier
pour accueillir la coupe
du monde du golf plus d'une centaine
d'ouvriers jardiniers ont investi les
greens pour améliorer les 18 trous et
l'accueil du public
là on a retravaillé à des petites
améliorations sur des greens ou sur des
départs pour que vraiment les sportifs
puissent s'exprimer au mieux mais on a
aussi beaucoup travaillé pour la qualité
de l'accueil du public en faisant des
routes des plateformes qui vont
permettre au public de circuler de voir
le golf c'est que le greffon on a une
chance et qu'on peut aller au plus près
des athlètes et au plus près des
sportifs pour les voir donc
et on sait qu'on voudra énormément de
public ici les 200000 spectateurs
attendus a dû en cours pour la ryder cup
pourront également observé un parcours
plus visuel avec une dizaine de nouveaux
bon coeur des points d'eau vont
également être créés sur le site
il ya eu des changements et un
changement déjà durant ce parce que
c'était un trou qui manquait un peu de
caractère et on avait besoin d'un
endroit pour stocker de l'eau donc déjà
deux bonnes raisons pour le faire
et puis les deux autres changements qui
vont être marqués sur le green du 1 et
les greens du 16 mai qui en étaient
rendus plus juste pour le joueur mais
aussi plus facile à gérer lors d'un gros
événement donc sinon il n'y a pas de
changement notoire
ils disent assez difficile les travaux
de rénovation devrait s'achever en avril
2016 les golfeurs pourront jouer à
nouveau sur l'albatros à partir de
décembre
mais ce sera sur un parcours réduit avec
seulement neuf trous le journal se
poursuit sur tv fil 78 temps ce jeudi et
chaque de jeudi dorénavant le point sur
vous rendez vous sportifs du week-end ce
sera avec michael et 1000 euros bonfort
mitterrand soir wilfried alors c'est la
reprise des championnats n'ont pas
encore tous repris pour l'instant
évidemment c'est septembre les
passionnés de rugby de basket ou encore
de handball devront encore patienter
jusqu'au week-end du 20 septembre pour
voir leur équipe favorite jouer mais
rassurez vous il faut y aura quand même
un match très important ce week-end
c'est le match entre montini bretons les
cougars de montier bretonneux mais
également les clermont ferrand stade
jean marc échappe donc à montigny cbs
bol c'est du baseball c'est ça du
baseball en demi finales de playoffs
c'est bien ça pour nous parler de cette
rencontre
nous recevons annick août ont donc la
présidente des cougars de montilly
bretenoux soir en soir bonsoir
alors est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
une performance pour montigny d'être
qualifiés en demi-finales de play-off de
2e
oui c'est toute façon c'était l'objectif
que l'on s'était fixé en début de saison
donc nous devions atteindre les
play-offs donc nous les avons obtenus
obtenu maintenant nous devrons rencontré
clermont ferrand qui est notre bête
noire puisque en 2016 nous étions déjà
en demi finale de championnat de france
contre eux et nous avions été battus et
cette année les quatre rencontres que
nous avons eues contre clermont ferrand
nous à nous les avons perdus aussi
donc nous avons notre revanche à prendre
ce week end et ses équipes qui vous a
battu quatre fois en quatre rencontres
cette année d'ajustement comment allez
vous faire pour pour tout simplement
remporté la victoire à la balle est dans
le camp des joueurs c'est le cas de le
dire mais de toute façon ils sont
motivés et tout est possible tant que
les matchs ne sont pas finies donc je
pense qu'ils ont leurs chances surtout
que cette année nos lanceurs ont fait de
bonnes performances
nous avons eu un peu moins de chance au
bâton donc ils vont ils vont s'entraîner
là les deux ce soir et vendredi soir
pour pouvoir accéder à un meilleur bâton
et si vous deviez faire un pronostic sur
cette rencontre jeu il faut que l'on
gagné de match mais en tout cas où
d'encourager tout le monde à venir au
stade
c'est ça nous encourageons tout le monde
à venir au stade ce sera un beau match
de baseball
et vous comptez peut-être sur certains
joueurs en particulier oui ce sont nos
lanceurs oui et puis sur les anciens
joueurs qui peuvent à un moment donné
faire basculer le match par leur
expérience du haut niveau et compteront
sur le soutien du public c'est ça tout à
fait merci à une écoute on est passé sur
plateau on croise les doigts pour les
cougars de montigny-le-bretonneux et on
vous suivra ans continuera à vous suivre
la semaine prochaine également pour la
demi finale retour
merci beaucoup evènement également bien
évidemment rassurez vous et il n'y aura
pas que du baseball au également ce
week-end où il ferait dealer également
le championnat de football qui vont
redémarrer en promotion d'honneur trappe
reçoit villemomble au stade de gilbert
chance à qu'une rencontre à la portée
des trappistes les footballeurs saint
quentinois avait terminé la saison
dernière dans les cinq premiers après
avoir été relégable pendant une grande
partie de la saison
cette fois-ci trappe vab veut bien
entamé la saison pour monter cette année
pour les encourager rendez vous à 15
heures ce dimanche toujours en football
mais cette fois ci en division
excellence l'équipe première de
versailles reçoit la troisième
de poissy dimanche à 15 heures au stade
mont boron la rencontre qui risque
d'être serré les deux équipes étaient au
coude à coude la saison dernière enfin
il y aura un derby à ne pas manquer ce
week-end à saint quentin en yvelines et
l'encours soit magny les hameaux
en début de 2e division de district pour
le compte de la première journée et
devrait y avoir du spectacle manille a
terminé parmi les meilleures attaques du
championnat la saison dernière
la rencontre est programmée dimanche à
15 heures au stade guy-boniface voilà
wilfried vous connaissez tous les rendez
vous sportifs du week-end dans le
département et on a bien vu mais le
baseball le softball c'est bon avec
annick rouchon la présidente qui est
venu nous voir ce soir mickaël on vous
retrouve aussi lundi puisque les
différentes émissions sur tv fil 78
devons reprendre progressivement leur
rythme pour cette nouvelle saison donc
lundi de 18h30 ça ne change pas 19h30
23h pour les première rediffusion
reprise 17,8 sports au programme
c'est ça il y aura du golfe avec la les
travaux pour la ryder cup 2018 mais il a
également un petit tour de table
rugby avec les club yvelinois mais
également la coupe du monde de rugby et
notamment
hédi ben arous le trappistes qui a été
sélectionné merci michael on retrouve
donc lundi sur cette antenne je vous
parlais d'éducation si vous me suivez
depuis le début de ce journal la
connexion avec un manque la jolie n'a
pas été rétablie pour revenir sur cette
conférence de presse de rentrée de la
fsu le syndicat enseignant a malgré tout
dès demain dans le journal vous
retrouverez le reportage complet préparé
par mail et fanny bourdillon un dernier
mot tout de même d'éducation le
directeur académique de versailles qui
était l'invité du journal hier vient de
tenir une conférence de presse
aujourd'hui
il a répété que la rentrée avait été
sereine ce sont à ces mots de cette
conférence de presse
on retiendra que l'on compte 2000 élèves
de plus qu'en 2014 sur notre secteur que
l'accent sera mis sur deux dossiers en
particulier notamment le numérique axes
importants de head développement on
écoute non journal côté culture à
présent difficile reprise 1 pour cette
semaine informations qui concernent à
maurepas à la mairie a lancé à
l'opération elle livre échange un
principe qui est assez simple une boîte
vous allez l'avoir à l'image il y en a
quatre sur la commune chacun vient d'y
déposer un livre repart avec un autre un
système d'échangé de partage et devant
le succès ça va se poursuivre toute
l'année et cette fois ci on écoute une
interview au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude c'est permettre à des gens
éloignés de la médiathèque qui
jamais à la médiathèque de pouvoir
consulter des livres qui ont été
appréciés par des mort d'asia
voilà qui donc il dit paul qui pose
librement leurs livres dans cette boîte
ce sont des échanges de livres
littérature également avec demain
vendredi à partir de 20 heures la
librairie le pavé du canal à montigny le
bretonneux qui va proposer une soirée
exceptionnelle les lecteurs vont
échanger avec les bibliothécaires autour
des nouveautés de la rentrée chacun va
défendre son coup de coeur en ce mois de
septembre pas moins de 580 nouveaux
ouvrages qui sont recensés cette
présentation va être faite d'une part
par les libraires mais aussi par des
clients des bons vecteurs des fidèles
lecteurs à qui on a donné des livres cet
été à lire et qui vont venir nous les
raconter là à partir de 20h pourquoi pas
partager cette grosse rentrée littéraire
avec tout le monde plutôt que ce soit 10
mg est disséminée avec juste un ou deux
clients là vraiment de présenter en une
seule fois
tout cette grande rentrée et puis aussi
cet échange de ses lecteurs qui avaient
vraiment envie de venir nous faire
partager toutes les lecteurs qu'ils
avaient eues durant l'été donc on leur
dit venez chez nous et puis parler de
parler de vos livres que qui vous ont
plu
je rappelle la mobilisation des
agriculteurs aujourd'hui qui a touché
notamment les yvelines ils étaient
nombreux à se rendre sur paris reportage
complet à revoir sur notre site internet
si vous n'étiez pas avec nous au début
de cette édition de demain vendredi
l'essentiel de l'actualité de la journée
mais aussi l'essentiel à retenir de la
semaine en compagnie de benoît hamon
l'ancien ministre député des yvelines
candidat aux régionales en ile-de-france
sera mon invité et donc demain
excellente soirée sûreté des fils bien
sûr